près de 1000 acteurs importants du monde
des nouvelles technologies rassemblés à
montréal
un concours d'entreprises en démarrage
les fameuses start up était organisée
par le prestigieux site techcrunch la
semaine dernière mathieu bonsoir jean
cellular de quoi s'agissait-il
c'est un genre de version accélérée de
l'émission les dragons on connaisse ou
des entreprises entrepreneurs au nombre
de dix doivent présenter en 60 secondes
leur projet donc ça va très vite la
piste qui a gagné c'est une entreprise
qui s'appelle make-up blocks
retenez ce nom françois poirier derrière
ça et qui se présente comme un genre de
l'ego du 21e siècle mais que blocks part
de la prémisse que aujourd'hui faut
enseigner la programmation aux jeunes
donc six ans et plus la même manière
dont on enseigne l'écriture de calcul ou
encore la mémoire et bien et comment ça
fonctionne mais c'est très intéressant
c'est un hybride entre d un jeu de bloc
est une application donc il faut
assembler les blocs pour créer des
instruments électroniques comme par
exemple un système d'alarmé ou encore un
micro qui change le timbre de la voix
on peut aussi avec un jeu sur
l'application résoudre des casse tête
avec les blocs dans la réalité est là
caméra de la tablette regarde ça et ils
nous disent on ne réussit ou non alors
donc meilleur blog ci a gagné quelles
sont les prochaines étapes force mais
ils s'en vont ennuyer donc mais que
blocks va new york pour le gros
événement international au début mais
après ça ils vont aller au mercure faire
ça c'est à san francisco c'est le plus
gros événement du genre à san francisco
et donc tout ça pour intéresser la
presse et d'éventuels investisseurs à
une ronde de financement de sociaux
financement qui auront lieu sur
kickstarter
et ça ce sera à la mi mai donc on compte
beaucoup sur la presse qu'il y aura
autour de ça pour pouvoir intéresser des
gens à financer ces entreprises et des
compagnies comme celle là il y en a
plusieurs l'a déjà mans cet incroyable
en heure on y en aurait mille
actuellement à montréal
et il ya déjà un environnement un
écosystème autour de ça pour les
soutenir dans leur croissance comme par
exemple font du fuel ou éco fio donc on
il y en a de plus en plus et ça a donné
des succès déjà il ya des jeux de très
beaux succès on pense à franck hainaut
par exemple qui est un magasin de détail
vêtements pour hommes en ligne il ya
aussi l'application bruit 2 qui est un
genre de airbnb qui permet de louer des
espaces de bureaux pour un court temps
ou encore beauce bad qui permet de
comparer des voyages en autobus
un peu partout du monde ont déjà des
beaux succès dans le monde de la start
up à montréal en termes de financement
là on n'est peut-être pas on était un
petit peu en retard est en retard quand
on compare par exemple à l'ontario en
ontario le financement de la start-up
équivaut environ à 932 millions de
dollars au québec on est qu à 295
millions dont tu m'aimes
proportionnellement parlant on ya encore
un écart mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que les événements comme celui qu'on a
connu la semaine dernière l'événement
techcrunch sa place montréal comme un
pôle international de l'ast de la start
up et donc éventuellement pour des
investisseurs ça devient intéressant
parce qu'il ya déjà des beaux succès et
c'est une excellente nouvelle ce à la
fois pour la créativité ici mais aussi
pour l'économie belge
oui du bien plaisir